hi my name is Felix but I'm probably
better known on YouTube as Pierre de
path as most of you already know not
everyone in the world has access to
clean water but did you know that lack
of clean water and lack of sanitation
leads to more deaths than any form of
violence and that includes war children
are the ones worst affected by this and
90% of deaths are coming from children
under the age of five there is a water
crisis going on in our world right now
with over 1 billion people suffering
from it every single day but it is a
solvable crisis and I'm hoping with my
recent popularity on YouTube and
together with you bros and anyone who's
willing to help make a difference that
we can do it we're starting a charity
water campaign for my dot charity
water.org slash pewdiepie it's an
amazing charity and a hundred percent of
what you donate goes to actually helping
people our goal is to hit two hundred
and fifty thousand dollars which is a
lot of money but there are 10 million of
us right now and if everyone just pitch
in I know we can reach it I will donate
one dollar for every 500 views this
video gets so basically my maximum is
ten thousand dollars then I really hope
you will share this video around and you
can go ahead and make me broke it's for
a good cause my network maker Studios
has offered to match my donation as well
we're gonna get help from a lot of
different companies and sponsors to go
ahead and check the link in the
description people walk hours every
single day to reach access of unclean
water that might even be what kills them
and their family by giving water to a
village even through simple measurements
as building a well it takes that time
away that they can spend on getting an
education taking care of their family
life begins with water and these things
are only the start so 250 thousand can
we do it Bros I think we can I will do a
lot of live streams I will do everything
I can to get this going but I need you
bros help for this so check out the link
in the description and I would like to
end it with a quote from Anne Frank
which is no one has ever become poor by
gaming let's do this bro